a little bit from AOC because she is not
happy that Mandela Barnes lost his race
for Senate in Wisconsin to Ron Johnson
and you're not going to believe it guys
quick get you got to secure yourself in
your seat you know what she's blaming
this on yeah racism I think there's no
there's an argument to be made
missiles too much
according to identify ourselves strongly
as who we are I I think Tim Ryan ran a
phenomenal race Mandela Barnes ran a
great race I think there are racial
Dynamics in that race that need to be
discussed in terms of how Republicans
targeted a a black man running in that
race and I think that that needs to be
just put out there
man AOC you you are just such a clown I
I it is so unfortunate that she is still
part of this government you know what's
interesting there she says there she
talks about two races Tim Ryan so Tim
Ryan lost obviously to JD Vance in Ohio
and then uh Mandela Barnes who lost to
Ron Johnson in Wisconsin so she's upset
about these two losses
um Tim Ryan is white so obviously oh
well he's white I guess he just lost we
don't know exactly why but of course the
black guy Mandela Barnes has to lose
because of racism it's not because there
was all this crazy video of him talking
about releasing prisoners back into the
streets and defunding the police and
everything and the rest of his bad
Progressive ideas it can't have anything
to do with that it has to be because
he's black Tim Ryan will have to figure
it out there must have been some other
reason with Tim Ryan because he's white
he's got white privilege he was running
against another white guy whiteness
Rises to the top or something like that
and uh with uh with Mandela Barnes no
it's got to be racism and that is a
fundamental difference I would say
between uh blue and red which is that
when when Democrats lose they blame the
Republic Republicans in the base and
they blame America because America is
racist and bigoted and hates women and
all of that stuff right that's generally
what they go to exactly what AOC did
right there Republicans when they lose
and Republicans are sort of taking this
thing as a loss even though I said
Republicans going to get the house it
wasn't it's not a total loss and we'll
see what happens with the Senate
but you know what Republicans seem to be
doing Republicans really seem to be
going man which way do we have to go in
this thing do we have to think about
this different was a guy like Dr Oz a
real mistake because look we ended up
with fetterman so maybe we don't want
these Hollywood type people even though
someone like me kind of came around on
him but maybe that was a real mistake
there maybe if you take people like
Blake Masters again who I like and
Carrie Lake who I like that these were
people who were not in politics before
and you ran both of them uh in Arizona
maybe that was a mistake like
Republicans all and I can tell you this
from sitting here with Rand Paul and
with Jim Jordan and I'm going to
continue talking about it this week with
other Republicans are all kind of going
well what can we do a little bit
differently here do we have to go more
the Trump route is there more of a
DeSantis party like what what are the
policies that we have to have as opposed
to just being like no it's because the
the Democrats are all racists or all
socialists or whatever it's like what
can we do and that's I think how you
refine ideas and get better so that is a
bit of a silver lining to all of this